[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
is here welcome everybody to an episode
of jk news where we talk about whatever
we want david is here
mama i know i haven't been here for a
minute but we still don't eat on camera
what are you talking about
we're at a baseball game guys stop it
man
yeah you look like it i don't i don't i
don't like baseball they bought one of
the most boring sports
okay it's koreatown or a dumbfounded
it's a downfoundant
what about 92 what does that mean i
think he's born in 92. i think he was
born in
ninety two 1892. a ninety is a nineties
baby like that uh absolutely not that
was old as [ __ ] he's all right yeah i
got young people tendencies maybe that's
when he came to korean town that's the
first time he lost his virginity
in koreatown in the butt in the butt
butt virginity virginity first
i'm scared of that one that's true
you're scared of that one one of the
most horrific stories you ever told was
when you [ __ ] somebody in the ass little
dookie came out with it yeah i will
never forget i was sitting right there
it was during [ __ ] ass
you could almost smell it that's where
dookie comes out of
like don't [ __ ] there then but why do
people like i asked play
i think they just want to do stuff that
you're not supposed to do and that's to
turn on right well you guys think it's
really tight they're like oh so tight
actually
i accidentally stuck it in a booty hole
one time and it was pretty amazing but
then
wait wait wait wait wait wait fast
forward you can't accidentally
stick it in there especially for the
girl now she's loose as [ __ ] i know but
no she was she
i went and she's like ow what the
[ __ ] issue with
she was ready for it it was like
relaxing because you have to go
slow i was like 19 or 20. it was in the
spoon position
and then i put it in that way yeah
rock hole and it went inside it went
whoa
because that could make her bleed the
head part and i was like oh my god that
was sensational
and i was like oh okay but at that time
i never had them i never had the butt
sex so
at that time i fantasized about it
because in pornos and all these things
it's like so sexual i mean it's it's hot
there's such a process what porno people
have to do that they
use that whole [ __ ] out cleaning which
most people don't be told
right and then you go out and do it and
you try it and you're like that's
not so you accidentally put it in there
she wasn't ready for it
like she maybe she it was the more no no
this is a different story different
person
different story i was like that incident
didn't involve her booty hole okay
it didn't involve cocka it was actually
pleasant i just remembered
so she was ready for it then but not
ready
maybe she was fasting
he didn't go further in like deep enough
i don't know but this was
yeah that's like when i was 20 or
something so that was really really
different time oh but the one you did
i'm talking about the [ __ ] with the
dangling off the dick oh dude did you
hear that off that dick
i don't know why i imagined it just on
the bed you know what i've been thinking
about i remember he
dangling off this dick dude so like one
of her hairs were in there
oh my god my [ __ ] dog be eating
[ __ ] hair off the floor have you ever
like i have to like help there was this
one time where i saw a hair sticking on
my cat's butt and i was like
oh my god i put gloves on i'm like let
me know what i've seen
you know tyson right this one ate
everything one time
this fool was spent over and he was
pooping and i'm like he was stuck
what is that and then it was a toilet
paper i mean a paper towel
and then it was like rolled up and i'm
like out he was like a paper dowel
dispenser and i was pulling out
it was like a magician it was like this
long a straight-up painting yeah
that long yes and it was all twisted up
because i guess it goes all up in there
and it was twisted it was all yellow and
brown
was it the roll or was it oh is this
taika or
no
what did you eat taika dude i legit
registered taika and i should blew my
mind that was tyson
he ate paper towels all the time dogs be
eating hair on the floor man they're so
dumb i think they eat it on purpose i
think they're eating something around it
and it's so happy
she's so [ __ ] weird because she knows
when when a [ __ ] dingleberry is on
her so she gets
ashamed and then she'll poop and she'll
feel something on and then she'll run
away and hide under the couch
i'm like do you have a bunch of
dingleberries underneath here so i'm
like so i'm like what the [ __ ]
the first time she did it i'm like
rubber butt on the floor
no she just waits because she's just
sitting there i'm like what are you
doing come here and she wouldn't come so
i grabbed her out
and lo and behold i see a nunchuck
hanging out oh my god
hold up and you just go it's a long ass
[ __ ] piece of hair this big oh
yeah that was the hair yeah and it
happened multiple times so what happens
is that hair actually
i guess like dookie forms around the
hair so it's literally a [ __ ]
nunchuck dude
wait what were you talking about nothing
there's not directions
so speaking of [ __ ] one time uh jess had
came over we were like in the hot tub
and we're just talking and tyke is
swimming with us
and he has uh i heard this uh he has his
trunks and [ __ ] and like i don't have
him with swim diapers or anything
so he just gets out and i don't know
where he goes mama i have to kaka
and then he just what i'm like no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait
and then he just he didn't wait and he
took a [ __ ] right in front of [ __ ]
right by the board i'm like holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do now
at least it's not in the pool thank god
it was like inches did he hold on no
it wasn't inside no it was like he i had
enough time to take his shorts off but
then it just
wasn't a little bit in the pool and then
like just
like cup under the water and there was
dookie on the wall
a dookie on the water in her hand and i
was like damn those are some auntie
instincts
like she just went under and the dookie
was still floating on the water and she
went like that
dude i got so many child horror hakka
stories
yeah kaka's story someone see you like
one that wasn't me but someone saw you
at like ride it or something and that
was literally when
uh isaac took a [ __ ] oh i forgot that
part i think
who saw you someone saw you and he took
a [ __ ] on himself no so isaac
ever since he started potty training
ever since i tried potty training him he
always had this tendency to never
understand his body even until he's 12
sometimes he's like oh [ __ ] i actually
have to go
but this one time we were at rite aid
and i had to
do an errand and then immediately he's
like mom i need to poke now
right now and i was like holy crap okay
wait where's the bathroom
it was too late he already took a [ __ ]
and like i was like
why do you do this it literally happened
so many times where he's like
i i it's an emergency that he has to go
pee so i'm like okay he has to pee okay
we got we got that handled he peed but
then like 10-15 minutes later
i have to poop now like it's and it just
comes out what
so many times he had [ __ ] and his pants
wow cause i'm like at least you were at
home you know i understand that though
sometimes sometimes you get distracted
and you ignore it
and then it just attacks you out of
nowhere so it's like you gotta pee but
then you figure you gotta [ __ ] it too
dude how many times have i shed him
like in public like i get where he's
coming from what what's wrong with you
he's an adult
you know this [ __ ] i only know what why
you be [ __ ] in public [ __ ] what's
wrong with you
that mean what's good escaping it's all
folks what's going on she's a
libertarian
yeah there's just not a bathroom that's
easily accessible you know
hold that [ __ ] you can't hold this in a
no sometimes it's like
you just have to [ __ ] go now whoa for
me the only time i have those feelings
is when i'm already peeing and then i
realize
oh i have to poop and that's what i'm
pooping but i never know beforehand
though i don't poop
that's good you guys ever pee at a
public stall and it makes you relax too
much and you just start farting out of
nowhere and then you [ __ ] on yourself
i'm just kidding just kidding wait do
you mean standing up because when you're
standing and then you forget that other
people oh i do it all the time but i
don't care people i don't think guys
care about guys oh i care a little bit
but i'm just paying all of a sudden i
start ripping one and i'm like did i
just fart
i'm like oops my badge oh wake yourself
up from the party
absolutely not i did i wake myself
i don't fart but i can imagine you're
perfect you ever fart so hard that you
wake up like that yeah yeah i've never
had that
i'm a deep sleeper you're like what was
that noise
there's no one else i sleep talking like
crazy like a [ __ ] yes
and you and mario should talk to each
other in your phone did you have a
sleepover
last time um well steve steve has
learned not to
engage like a as if i'm a real person
um because i sound like i'm actually
talking but i'm not saying the correct
words so
i'm like honey am i out of am i an
avocado
and like before he'd be like no you're
not an avocado and then i'd get pissed
at him like
oh you don't think i'm an avocado okay
whatever and i get all [ __ ]
mad are your eyes open too yeah my eyes
are open are you like
up right or are you in the bed and just
looking out no i'm like i it usually
happens if i fall asleep downstairs
on the couch because he's like trying to
take me to bed so like he's like okay
come on let's go to bed and like come on
avocado i'm an avocado and so he learned
to just like agree with anything i said
yeah so he's like yeah yeah you are and
poor man dude the [ __ ] that he has to
deal with that is [ __ ]
nuts dude but he does it too remember
that one time he fell asleep
and then we were like trying to get him
to leave and he was just like oh
he does that when he's drunk yeah when
he's drunk he
talks and he's always defending how he's
not drunk i'm not drunk
i'm not asleep i'm not sleeping yeah i
could drive i could drive yeah
wasn't i talking the last time you said
that i was saying something
like you like cut like spooned me
at least the stuff you say is like
coherent because like mario does stuff
that scares me so like the other
like not too long she did a [ __ ] where
we were sleeping well i wasn't sleeping
but she was
and i don't know where she i'm going to
imitate exactly how she screamed and i'm
like
oh what the [ __ ] and i wake her up and
she goes oh my god
i was walking down a hall and then there
was a door and somebody pushed me over
and i was falling down so her screaming
was her falling down some stairs she
goes
[Laughter]
if we had somebody that could film this
like and went to film school
your [ __ ] is funny this video is brought
to you by
full sail university baby that's right
located just outside orlando florida
full sail university
offers associates bachelors and master's
degrees designed
for the world of filmmaking music gaming
art and technology
offered both online and on campus these
programs are accelerated so you can earn
your degree
in half the time degrees are immersive
and hands-on so you can learn your craft
using the same tools and technologies
found in the industry
full sail grads are able to come back
and audit classes throughout their
careers
so you keep learning and receive
lifetime career development support
throughout their professional journey
wholesale grads have gone on to do big
things
like working at jk films and jk news and
jk party and
mixing hit records like special feelings
to working on major hollywood films to
winning oscars grammys
and more enrolled students receive a
laptop along with
industry software at a deep
institutional discount to learn more
about full sales programs as well as
potential
scholarship opportunities visit
wholesale.edu off the record
that's fullsale.edu off the record thank
you full sail
when you were a kid did you think that
orlando was like the most magical place
yes because everything was there and it
was all like visit the nickelodeon
studio in orlando in the universal
studios
orlando disney world in orlando i
remember in fifth grade we were doing
like a
like a states project class where like
the teacher was okay everyone's gonna do
a project or report on the states you
have to do like a presentation do you
pick florida no no so you're just
passing it out right
when it landed on my desk and i was like
oh florida
i was like yes and i remember like 20
other kids like oh
cause they wanted it yeah they all
everyone wanted florida wait so you take
it florida
i got florida too i picked it because
that's where uh they
instinct lived oh [ __ ] yeah i didn't get
to uh
pick it but then she just gave it to me
i don't remember anything educational
growing up at all
for reals yeah i don't remember any
lesson are you sure yeah
no what parade baby is that where the
mexican [ __ ] the [ __ ]
mission
[Music]
[Music]
is it the pch i don't remember anything
the only thing i remember is going to
this place called sky park
and then i was scared of heights that
sounds fun it doesn't sound educational
that's
where i go to the bike park oh there was
this so this is place sky park
where uh i guess like we spent the
weekend over there and we learned like
forest nature [ __ ]
and then we would sleep and there was
this one girl i think her name was reyna
and i was very scared of heights and we
had a queen we had to climb up this
thing and then she would basically dust
in my eye she got so sick of me going up
slow
and she went she started climbing up
super fast dumb [ __ ] she embarrassed me
in front of everybody
did you guys ever listen
on the list the revenge list anyone
who's ever wronged david in any way he's
on a [ __ ]
head checkmark to you you'll see if you
meet somebody new and they'll say
something wrong i'm like
all right you added 1255. oh my god what
are you doing it's like no
you're on my list to the soul cow people
did you guys remember going on like
a pirate ship that was docked on the
side no
and then the captain would be like he's
like he's like all right we're going to
take sail for the seas everyone wave to
the pier
and then like all the kids turn around
and wave to the pier but then obviously
it's attached to the thing
so all the kids are like we're not going
to leave but then he's like still like
playing it up like really big
is that that age where you're like you
can't fool me folks like oh my god i was
like seventh grade and it's like we're
not that young dude did you guys ever do
that no but we actually went to catalina
island did you guys
cool no we had like uh see me it was
catalina island marine institute and we
spent a week there you gotta be in a
week yeah
the fifth graders we got to go yeah how
did you sleep without your parents
snorkeling that was the fun part because
the boy you had a crush on was like
right next door to you and you're like
i'm gonna wear my cute pajamas cool the
only thing we did was go whale watching
oh that's cool do some dope [ __ ] in
school man i did
none of this stuff really no my school
was [ __ ] this was public school too
yeah but you had to raise money for it
well i do i know we went on field trips
i just don't remember much
like i don't go to the zoo i never went
to a field trip that's a typical field
trip see i don't remember any of this
stuff like the only thing i remember
in elementary school was like little
fights little brawls
like that's the stuff i can remember
that like nothing what about sixth grade
survival mode dude maybe
it was a pretty rough did you go to
sixth grade camp no she was like yeah we
went
where was your sixth grade camp like
lake arrowhead or something oh ours was
space camp in idlewild
it's high yeah and it snowed while we
were there and it was so cool because i
had never seen it what's the space about
idlewild
well they just do they have like a
gyrosphere that you are part of it's
like a whole space can adults go
maybe i don't know yeah [ __ ] i don't
remember nothing i remember seventh
grade there was this dude
we were i was on my way home on the bus
what did he do to you
no there was this dude he didn't do
nothing to me this dude was on a bmx
bike and he did a drive-by on his other
kid
that's so funny wait what the [ __ ]
it was funny because he did a drive on a
bike it was hilarious yeah but we were
goodbye we were in the
it was a real ass gun with a [ __ ] gun
it was not a great school but we were in
the bus
and this kid was on a bmx bike and he
didn't [ __ ] drive by
that's uh david's position in the crew
he's always the the energy's really high
and positive and he goes you know what
else happened then he like that's not
funny that's funny
tragic nobody died what the the first
time he ever did that's scary as [ __ ] no
he was talking about how
his friend was driving on the freeway
and then like this homeless man jumped
in front of his car but we had just
finished like laughing
and then he tells us that he isn't funny
we're like that guy was dead
what was that [ __ ] homeless man he could
have been i don't remember that anymore
though
but i was fresh in my head one jk
episode used that on where where the
energy was up here and then he's like
oh my friend's dog he was celebrating
his birthday and then his dog got
swooped up by an eagle and just take it
away
and i'm like that was kind of funny it's
funny that's
kind of funny but you have an idea how
hilarious did you see like this one mom
kid on a [ __ ] bmx box trying to do a
[ __ ] drive-by
that image was [ __ ] funny where's
that actual guy
the actual pedaling part you need to
paint the whole picture maybe he was on
this bmx bite
and we're on the bus and everybody was
laughing because of how hilarious it was
no you
weren't scared people got shot but that
wasn't like a big thing
usually it's in the car hey guys so hey
off the record when we shoot about some
more funny stories david
that's not funny guys that's this guy's
so you know come on now
he's laughing at you now come on now
come on now any drive by stories guys
i have one but it's not funny
that was the opposite so we were waiting
at a stop sign and then a dude on a bike
was was crossing in front of us and then
a car pulled up and then shot that guy
that was funny yeah but mom was on a
little bmx bicycle my mom was a reverse
a guy on a bicycle got shot yeah that's
sad
bring down the oh dude i think it's
funnier when the guy on the bike is
shooting now
he asked me you weren't laughing he
opened up the forum
he said anyone else but mine's funny
because it's a little tiny
i know but i just answered your it was
her only drive-by story
oh yeah yeah she said it's not funny
yeah thank you
that was the proper context my house got
shut up all the [ __ ] time
good morning oh you use that as a
doorbell jeez
that's how your mom woke you up get your
[ __ ] mail [ __ ]
bye bye tell your momma said hi dude my
mom just recently told me that uh my dad
for new year's eve this is when i was
really really small that they'd go out
in the front yard [ __ ] start shooting
in the air and i'm like we were that
[ __ ] family
oh my god there's a bullet hole in the
guy's kitchen
oh cause my dad was cleaning a rifle and
he didn't know that it was like oh my
god
that's dangerous it's still there yeah
this is because it was the guy
that had the bb gun and [ __ ] shot
your air conditioning unit
for alan
what happened that's one of the funniest
stories i forgot i forgot we're doing
we're just hanging on our backyard this
is like back early jk days where we hang
out in the back of uh like 619 in that
open area
and i had a pellet gun and then he was
like trying to shoot my neighbors [ __ ]
because our walls were low i'm like stop
shooting at my neighbor's house i'm like
shoot something in inside our house so
he was like he used a lot of shoes yeah
so he was like shooting like the the
little mandarin oranges that we have i'm
like stop
shooting things like shoot things that
are worthless i'm gonna eat those later
and then um out of nowhere i think he
shoots the ac
and i just hear like that and i'm like
did you just shoot the ac heels no
and then like we walk up to it and
there's the copper pipe there's a hole
in it with air like
coming out with still smoking because it
was like i guess it was like a
gas-filled pipe
i mean alex you [ __ ] shot that he
goes nah i don't think that was me
i was streaming out the wall i don't
think i'm like i think you aimed because
he was also like
a compulsive liar i'm like i think you
aimed directly at it and you shot it he
goes
i'll bring a check tomorrow
that guy's a unique human being man good
thing he's rich because he could pay for
all kinds of mistakes and he wrote me
like a 1700
check whoa i got a quote and that's how
much it costs he was like how did the ac
guy come and he was like how does he
even how did this even happen i'm like i
have a friend
he got my bb gun he shot it he goes like
the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you